uh the other thing in the news
related to impropriety and not getting
things done is the Supreme Court you
famously this summer there was a draft
opinion leaked that uh told the world
that the Supreme Court was going to
overturn Roe v Wade
and in subsequent months there's been an
investigation and I use heavy heavy air
quotes there an investigation to get to
the bottom of what took place and then
just a few days ago it came out that
though
we're we can't find the leaker we don't
know investigation over even though they
didn't interview any of the actual
justices everybody else involved had to
sign sworn affidavits under the penalty
of perjury that they were telling the
truth they had nothing to do with it but
the justices didn't nor did the
Justice's family because there is no
code of ethics there's no code of
conduct for the Supreme Court people who
make decisions that impact the lives of
360 million Americans aren't held to the
same standards that you are at your job
I'm going to read a little bit from the
CNN article entitled exclusive Supreme
Court did not disclose Financial
relationship with expert brought in to
review leak probe the Supreme Court did
not disclose its long-standing Financial
ties with former Homeland Security
secretary Michael chertoff even as it
touted him as an expert who
independently validated its
investigation into who leaked the draft
opinion overturning Roe v Wade the
Court's inquiry released last week with
chertoff's endorsement failed to
identify who was responsible for the
unprecedented leak the decision to keep
the relationship with church off quiet
is a reflection of a pattern of opacity
at the nation's highest court whose
rulings affect every American
now this relationship is worth a million
or so dollars to Michael chertoff
they pay him the court pays him has paid
his firm about a million dollars so the
reason that this stinks is the fact that
he has an incentive he has a motive to
do the bidding of the Supreme Court and
sign off on this BS investigation
because if he goes the other way if he
goes against the court that money very
well could dry up
I believe the days of holding and high
esteem the Supreme Court of the United
States are over
it is an absolute activist Maga Court
you've got your your Neil Gorsuch your
Sam Alito yours Clarence Thomas your
Brett Kavanaugh John Roberts used to be
one of the worst and now he looks like a
good guy in comparison
it is terrible and they're Shameless
about it they have no I mean the mask is
off they don't care if you know
I'm going to continue reading here CNN
has learned from sources familiar with
the arrangements that the court in
recent years has privately contracted
with the shirt off the chertoff group
excuse me for security assessments some
broadly covering Justice's safety and
some specifically related to covid-19
protocols at the court itself the
estimated payments to his risk
assessment firm for consultations that
extended over several months and
involved a review of the justices homes
reached at least a million dollars
and here we go again no transparency or
opacity as CNN said it the exact amount
of money paid could not be determined
Supreme Court contracts are not covered
by federal public disclosure rules and
elude tracking on public databases they
don't have to follow the same rules that
even Congress does and Congress doesn't
have to follow the same rules that the
rest of the country does
the justices have long cloaked
themselves in secrecy to the point of
declining to respond to questions about
potential conflicts of interest or to
reveal information about some court
rules and ethics codes or to release
timely information about the Justice's
health and public appearances
this is all gross
if they want to to maintain some air of
credibility we need
a code of ethics for the Supreme Court
and how we get that is Congress
in the Constitution Congress is given
the power to organize the courts they
could do this they could have done it
last Congress they could have done it
the Congress before they could have done
it the Congress before but they sit on
their hands because it is not in their
best interest to wreck to to to to to to
rock the boat
it's it's all
a bit much
again I would love to see you subscribe
to me on YouTube Jesse dollar more
follow me on social media I'm at Dollar
Moore on on Instagram on Twitter and
tick tock
I'd love to see you there